(upbeat music)
- Creativity is really important for me
as like a future job, as
a part of my future job
I would want to do something that changes
and then I can use problem
solving skills constantly.
I feel like when I make
animations or when I figure
out how to explain something,
I love that because there's
so many different solutions,
but knowing that you can
try to find and experiment
with different ones and maybe
create something beautiful
is really, I don't know, inspiring to me.
- Mathematicals educational initiative
that I co-founded with
a fellow mathematician,
Jess Williams.
And what we're trying to do is
make maths fun and accessible
and encourage more girls
to pursue careers in maths.
So creativity is essential here
because we're trying to think
of ways that people will enjoy maths
and it will be fun and accessible to them.
So different creative
techniques that we've been
using are trying to present
mathematical problems
in fun, short videos, and
that explain the problem
in a way that everybody will understand
and will make them want to learn more
and discover more about the
topics that we're talking about.
- I'm really lucky
that I get to be creative
every day in my work
and I have been since I got
into this field of data science.
So in general, across the last decade,
my work has really been about designing
and testing innovative ways
to capture human behavior
within game-based assessments.
So my collaborators and I,
from the time I was in
graduate school to now,
use a variety of different
modeling techniques
from various fields,
we'll pull things from
engineering, aerospace,
more basic mathematical models
to help us achieve this goal.
We get to think outside the box.
We get to think about how we
can pull in different types
of thinking from different
fields to help us better
understand human behavior,
human cognition, learning.
So it's really exciting and really novel.
And it's something that because
of the field that I'm in
I've been able to do this
now for multiple years.